baby arthur's progressive disorder
means he struggles to move his arms and
legs he can't lift his head
untreated he'd be unlikely to live
beyond two
but at five months he has no idea he's
receiving the most expensive medicine
in the world and the relief that that
has brought for his father
spinal muscular astrophy is the most
common genetic cause of death in
childhood
and around 40 children a year are born
with the most severe form
arthur is the first in england to be
treated on the nhs with a new gene
therapy that costs
almost 2 million pounds as well as the
becoming stronger in the muscles and
therefore potentially
being able to um roll and sit
and crawl and stand um we
also see that some of the children
treated with sultan smile are able to
speak infants with type 1 sma
become very weak in the feeding muscles
so that
they are unable to
feed normally and yet with treatment
we can see that they are more likely to
be able
to feed independently and not need to
rely on tube feeding
the soul gensma gene therapy will be
used at hospitals in london manchester
sheffield and bristol
despite its high price it was
recommended for use on the
nhs a landmark deal that will help
dozens of children like arthur yeah
we're absolutely over the moon
we're so grateful and happy whose father
sent this video
thanking hospital staff in the nhs
we're over the moon for their part in a
pioneering treatment
that baby arthur will one day hear all
about ali fortescue
sky news